You might be wondering why you should
be learning about exploratory data analysis in the
first place. Hal Varian, the cheap economist
at Google, said what's becoming ubiquitous and cheap?
Data. And what is complementary to data?
Analysis. In general terms, exploratory data analysis or
EDA. Is the examination of data and relationships
among variables, through both numerical, and graphical methods.
It often takes place before more formal, more
rigorous statistical analyses. EDA is often the first
part of a larger process. It can lead
to insights, or new questions, or even feed
into the process of building predictive models. It's
also an important line of defense against bad
data. It's an opportunity to check some of
your assumptions and intuitions about a data set.
Many times, business decisions are made using unpolished
visualizations that come out of exploratory data analysis.
Other times, you might polish some of those
visualizations or summaries before presenting them to a
larger audience. Let's hear from Chris about an
example of how EDA can fit into the
larger process of building predictive models. A great
example of EDA comes from the Netflix prize competition.
Teams competed for a million dollar prize to improve
the Netflix movie recommendation system by at least 10%.
You can read more about the contest and results
By clicking on the link in the instructor notes.
This visualization was created by Todd Holloway to show
clusters of movies based on movie ratings. Movies that
are closer together, receive similar movie ratings, whether those
ratings are high or low. And it's exactly this
type of visualization that allows us to get a feel
for the data and determined what could be a part
of it and what could be explored in more depth.
So, even before performing complex data analyses on the data,
we can learn a lot about visualizing our data. Nathan
Yau, a noted statistician and visualization guru provides his reflections
about this plot. You can read his thoughts and check
out the interactive visualization from the instructor notes as well.
So, whether you want to learn an in-demand skill
Or compete in $1,000,000 competitions. EDA has something to offer
to you. At the least, learning about EDA will
improve your ability to reason through data, sharpen your communication
skills, and expand your career opportunities. Now I want
you to take a few minutes to think about your
previous work and your educational experiences. Write a few sentences
about why you would like to learn about EDA And
once you've got your ideas down, share
your thoughts and your experiences in the forum.
And remember, there's no right or wrong
answer here. This question is just for you.